three two one here we go
hey what's up my name is samuel leeds
and i wanted to introduce you
to a student of mine and her name is
nazi she's doing really good things
within social housing and rental rent
she's financially independent
making a very very good monthly income
from doing it
and i thought i'd interview her and
share her success and her story and how
she's made it possible so nozzy thank
you so much for coming down to my house
oh thank you samuel for having me i'm
really excited to be here
so looking forward to it i'm a bit
nervous but yeah i'm really excited well
you know what
it's a really good thing because you've
been successful and now in sharing
you're going to have other people become
successful so where did this all
start and where did this all come from
oh where do i even start
um i actually never had any inclination
about
getting into property um the
only kind of property side i wanted to
do was to provide
housing and support for clients that
struggle to manage their
property their tenancies or live
independently
so my plan was to um get
accommodation from the local authorities
housing association
and support these clients to live
independently and manage their
their tendencies and you know move on
with their lives
um however i'd
registered a business with a friend of
mine
just to start the supported living
accommodation
but she was not really forthcoming
it was myself doing most of the work
then i thought
let me just go solo and do this myself
so i went online and started searching
on how to find these properties
and i came across your video and we're
talking about how you
can manage your property or support
somebody else's property
and make a profit out of it i just
thought
what how is that possible is it real
and i went on and binged on your videos
all your videos and spent the whole day
watching them
i didn't even wash the dishes on that
day and uh when they told my husband
about it
it was like no i don't believe that's
true
because i said to him yeah i i know what
you what you thinking but
from the videos from what i've watched
it seems very legit it's something that
you can do as a business
and say to your mom i've seen he's got
training coming up this week
and it so happened that it was october
school holidays
and i take an annual leave that week
and then i said to i'm going to book for
this training and call he was like
how are we going to manage with the kids
i said i'll go with them if i have to
they'll stay at a hotel because my
oldest is 16 year old 16 year old at the
time but now she's 18.
so they they'll stay at the hotel and
they'll attend the training
so what was the date of the training it
was the 18th of october do you know the
exact date
yes how can i forget how can you what
was it like
the crash course oh my goodness it was
just lit uh it's unexplainable
i was so motivated i was fired up and
when i left the crash course i just
thought
this is something i have to do it
resonated with me
somewhere somehow i just thought yeah i
have to go for this
okay so after the crash course you've
now learned
loads hopefully had your mind blown a
little bit
very very flawed i couldn't believe
there's so many strategies that you can
get into property in my head i thought
um property is for the rich
and the affluent only the only way i can
have
a property myself is to buy my own home
that i live in
and maybe later on save up money 15 20
years time and buy a second house
and maybe rent the other one property
but from the crash course i learned
quite a lot
how you can do rent to rent i can buy
refurbished refinance and rent
all those strategies they really blow me
out so since then
what how's life changed my life is
changed
so much i can tell you that um
i can't believe that from just a free
training
and i'm now earning money from property
which is more than my own salary
it might it doesn't seem a lot right now
but
yeah a lot has changed and your husband
as well
wasn't the most what should we say he
was a bit skeptical shall we say
he was mr skeptical didn't even come to
the crash course i didn't even come to
the crash course i was like
well i can't speak too badly of him
because he is in the corner of the room
but yeah of course he's been extremely
supportive of you oh yeah
yeah he was just skeptical of me i'm a
skeptical of the strategies
of the strategies not of you you are
skeptical of these strategies you just
thought
no i don't think that exists there's
anything wrong with being skeptical
i think being being skeptical and being
careful is okay
the problem is when you're
he supported you to do what you're doing
yeah and um
you've now succeeded very very well so
you've done
what what types what strategies have you
really ran with then
um so the strategy that really resonated
with me was rent to rent
yeah so i went straight away after the
crash course
i started making phone calls because i
thought i'm not used to contacting
agents i've
i don't have the the notes on what to
say
so i just i'll make as many phone calls
as i can until i get used to it someone
one day would say yes to me so i've made
about 100 phone calls
everybody was like no that's you you're
subletting
no landlord to accept that and things
like that
um but maybe a month after
the crash course um i identified the
property
in coventry which is a six bedroom
yeah and called the agent that property
had been on the market for about
i think three months so called the agent
they seem to understand about the
rent-to-rent strategy i was like oh yes
let me go for this now yeah so
we arranged the viewing and asked my
husband to come with me but he was
working
he was still not really hundred percent
sure
but after viewing the property i say to
you know what
that is the right property because from
the training you did say that
um you find properties that are a bit
kind of
run down a little bit yeah they would be
tired yeah because otherwise
if if they're in beautiful condition
they'd already get maximum rent so
it's a bit tired the landlord's
motivated maybe
he hasn't got the thousand pounds it
needs to just lift it up a little bit
and then you can get the best deal yeah
definitely yeah so it was a bit tired uh
six bedroom and it had only two tenants
um i think it was going for 1 200 pounds
per month
yeah and negotiate it to 1 000 pounds
and they're like oh bring the landlord
but i'm sure you'll be okay with that
so they called me two days later they
were like yeah the landlord agreed to
say it is fine you can go
for contract for two three years or five
years
if you wish so chose three years because
at that time was
still starting i just thought what if i
ran out of funds
yeah how would i manage yeah
so i started from then on um i
requested for a free rent
uh for about two and a half weeks yeah
yeah so
we signed on the 14th of december
um but the
the agreement started on the 1st of
january so we had about
two weeks um to turn around
the property perfect yeah you did very
well to get that i just have to commend
you because
you said you made about 100 phone calls
so many people would have given up
but the fact that you just kept going
and kept going um
and then within two weeks after the
crash course secured a regular rent i
mean massive congratulations
so talk to me about the figures then so
you agree to pay the landlord one
thousand pounds
what happened next so yeah two weeks to
get the property nice
spice it up yeah um i mean i mean how
much did that cost to renovate the
property
i think it cost about a thousand pounds
yeah to renovate it and
at that time actually i didn't have the
money and then i thought
okay the crash course samuel said you
can't get into property using other
people's money so why not
yeah i phoned my my young brother in
south africa
and he sent me some money and it so
happened that at that time
i was already starting a master's course
so i used part of my student loan
to to pay towards the house wow yeah
and we renovated it and my husband did
most of the renovations
when he saw that you were actually
serious yeah yeah right let's do it
together
yeah we even now we're doing everything
together he doesn't really have anything
yeah
he must be glad that you came to the
crash course and took the lead
on this oh he loves it he's like every
time i i trust his judgment just go for
it i trust your judgement that's it
so i think it's so important to have you
know a family
the support in what you're doing you say
you had a family back at home in south
africa that said you know what
i'll give you a thousand pounds or
whatever it was you've got your husband
that's working with you and i think
that's so
invaluable to have that so um you know
you're very very blessed
yeah oh yeah definitely i'm very
grateful because without
the support you just get deflated from
phone calls being turned down and you
not having finances
and don't having that support you just
get deflated and give up
that's right so one thousand pound a
month it cost you one thousand pounds to
renovate it
you had two and a half weeks rent free
period
um so it wasn't a lot of money there to
put down really
it wasn't a lot luckily um this property
already had um
fire doors all the fire alarm fitted
yeah
and so all we needed really was to
change flooring
uh paint the property and i think on the
ceiling as well it had
they'd put a wallpaper so they were
dangling
i remember towards the time for for
signing the agreement
the agent rang me was like no are you
sure you can turn this around look at
these pictures look how it is looking
this property is quite dilapidated
like no just leave it to me i'll do it
up we'll we will sort it out
yeah yeah so it's great yeah without
another thing as well as
you know having the skills to be able to
do that and make it happen
is also you know really important so
you're paying the landlord a thousand a
month do you still have that property
today
i still have that property so what
happened next so
what happened next uh beginning of
january time that's when we
we'd finished i think maybe three or
four rooms
and students we started flocking now to
coventry university
and put their rooms on adverts
they came most of the students came they
really wanted the rooms even those that
were not
ready they wanted to sign up yeah and
we signed up on about four students and
we void with two pro two rooms
um then after that
kovit came just a few weeks down the
line
yeah and we just thought yeah i hope
it's not going to affect us
but it did not slightly not a lot
because most of those students move back
with their families like we cannot
afford
to stay we are learning online now so
we might as well just go back home save
our money and we couldn't really argue
with them with this
it's their choice and just thought what
can we do
to to fill these voids to fill the gap
um i've contacted the council just
thought
with these a market out there the
councils they've got
a lot of people in emergency
accommodation that require
long-term accommodation so i already
work within the housing myself
so why not link with the coventry
council and told them that i've got
a few rooms available and if you if you
have any tenants that require
accommodation
you you can repair them to me
so yeah um i told them that i needed
the council to pay at least one month
rent and
deposit prior to the tenant moving in
so that strategy worked and they
referred four clients
that which helped fill the whole um the
whole place out incredible
so now is it just counts
for tenants from the council or have you
got students and some of the tenants
from the council oh no no it's
understood it's not it's only
uh tenants from the council so how much
rent are they paying now then
we're getting just over two thousand
pounds from that two thousand one
hundred and seventy pounds if i'm not
mistaken and you're paying the landlord
one thousand thousand and then you're
having to pay
bills yeah so how much profit does that
house give you it's giving me about 770
pounds
that's really good yeah wow how does it
feel to have that
it feels really really good i never
thought i'll have that extra 700 pounds
you know
in my life i was thinking if if you
needed any extra money just go and do a
part-time second job
get 30 pounds or 200 pounds here and
there but that extra
700 pounds it made a huge difference
and um all the profit you saved it up
and later used it to to use for another
property
as well which property is that this is a
second hmo i went to hmo okay
yeah from the same agent so we beat a
very good rapport with
with that agent and they now forward
properties to me
um every week and so i chose that
property because
it was really done up all n suites
four bedrooms and all in suites and um i
only advertised that for four students
and
even today is still filled up so are all
your properties full
all my properties are full and your
profit across
your rental rents how much are you
making in total profit um
about one thousand eight about one
thousand eight hundred pounds
yeah yeah and your job you say you're
earning a little bit more
with your income coming from rent than
you want from your job even
yes i i earned a lot more from the
property than i end from from my job
that's crazy yeah so why don't you just
do the property full time i will
eventually samuel i will i
i i love my job i feel like i i do make
a huge difference you know those clients
that i work with
relieve them from homelessness and yeah
and have a temporary accommodation
here and then move on into permanent
accommodation see them settle six
12 6 12 months it it
it fulfills me so you're really doing
this not just to make
money you're doing this because you want
to help people yeah i do it because i
want to help people
incredible yeah and and and you've got
any other stuff going on outside of
rental rentals rentals is that is that
all you all you've been doing
um no i've got three rental rent the
other one is a
rent to it's a rent to rent but it's
called um
a family that's living in it yeah and
so when i was crunching my numbers i
remember that the crash course i think
when you talk about they buy to let
or they they singulate sorry yeah that
most people will make about
at least if you're making 100 pounds 250
pounds
um it's usually enough for people but um
for that property it makes it a lot more
than that
yeah 270 pounds which is
uh which is quite good i think for
a single letter absolutely so you've now
got a few properties
you control them you're making about 1
750 pounds a month
that's coming in consistent what what's
the
with the council tenants is the money
that's coming in from the council is
that guaranteed or how does it work
oh yeah so my agreement with the council
and their tenants i've said to them i
only accept tenants
that will have their rent paid direct to
me
yeah from universal credit so initial
stage the
the council will pay um first month's
rent and deposit
and then going forward only direct
payments from from the
universal credit yeah so yeah it comes
direct
every month incredible yeah so how's
how's life changed then
from two years ago when you first came
to the crash course
to now now you've got your income coming
in from your job you've got your income
coming from your properties
what what what kind of differences has
that made in your everyday life
it's made a huge difference i still
can't believe that from
just the free training i've got so much
knowledge
i've gone and implemented taken action
and implemented and i'm getting a little
bit extra money
i can give my kids what they need
i mean when they can where is before
they were lacking
so a lot has changed for me yeah
and what are your plans for the for the
next 6 12 months
six to 12 months i'm planning on
buying refurbished and refinancing i've
already
bought one property recently
which is a very funny story actually to
tell go on what happened
and i was watching auctions
um i just thought you know what i'm in
property i might as well just lean
how does auction work so um
i went and burned the wolf i was
watching the properties i think i was
this was the
200 year property i was watching um i
noticed that people can beat on a
property
30 40 times you know or even 10 times i
just thought let me click a button to
say
a deep beat as well you know someone who
outbid me of course
yeah and soon after i clicked the button
i got a text message to say you won
wow yeah when did this happen
this was november 2020. so just a few
months back now
yeah just being crazy and how much how
much did you buy it for
it was 24 000. 24 000
where did you get the money from we had
we didn't have any money to be honest
it was such a very funny story um
so there was no money at all to pay for
the property
so i approached my bank i just thought
oh well uh
because of the the property that we live
in it does have equity
but we'd refine with um remortgaged
um a bit but when i applied for for the
um
extra loan they said we can only give
you six thousand pounds
i was like six thousand pounds which
will only cover the deposit towards the
property it won't cover everything
yeah yeah so um i used
a a financing loan um a preaching loan
okay so yeah use the preaching loan um
they they did a second attachment into
the property and then
um so you took a six thousand pound
lines of the deposit
wow they obviously thought it was a good
deal they
thought yeah but they attached the um
the loan into our current property where
we live in oh right
yeah yeah yeah i think because they they
knew it a bit and it's worth a lot more
so you bought it for 24 grand
yeah and you're gonna be have you
started renovations yet
we finished renovating are you finished
yeah we've finished this this is
a dark horse all right so you've bought
it for 24.
you've renovated it and how much is it
worth now
it's worth about 43 000 pounds and how
much did you spend on it
we spent just over 2 000 pounds
only 2 000. yeah wow hold on
where is this house it's in uh bishop
auckland
oh i know the area okay very cheap area
yeah
so you bought it for 24 you spent 2 000
on it yes you spent 26 000 in total
it's an hour 43 000 so what's the plan
the plan is to refinance it yeah when
it's refinance and get
all the money out and a little bit extra
and then use it
possibly for another rent to rent when
a more profit comes up in there wow so
that's another property
pull all your money out deal yeah
absolutely incredible so you're going
through the refinance now
yeah we're going to start the
refinancing absolutely brilliant how
does it feel then to just be like
i mean to be buying houses like that
that's just crazy
it is crazy
it it's called a serendipity moment
where you accidentally
get something really good by accident
yeah yeah
i i still can't believe it today that is
crazy that's from free knowledge from
you
oh wow it's great and that's the thing
the crash course is free
you know there is no catches and i think
a lot of people are very skeptical
about rental rents buying cheap houses
about the free training um you know what
would you say to people that were
that were even watching this video and
thinking i don't believe
it this sounds too good to be true what
would you say
i would say to them uh i'm here today
i'm doing property i never thought i'll
be here
um doing any rent to rent if you have
any
ideas about getting into property start
now
time will not wait for you and i would
advise you to
go for training uh whether it's buying a
book
read get more information and uh
take action yeah massive wise words
what's your strongest reason for doing
this
it's for my children yeah and for my
children and i i grew up looking
to be honest that i didn't have much
growing up where did you grow up
in zimbabwe oh in zimbabwe that's why
that's what we get on well then yeah
that's why we get on
yeah i grew up in zimbabwe we're not
affluent at all my father struggled to
educate us
so i mean even having
two pairs of shoes for me it was
it was um uh how how can i put it
if you have i use i would live with it
one pair of shoes throughout the year
so i don't want my children to lack so
this is why i'm doing it
to leave a legacy for them and teach
them
property as well so that in future
they'll be able to
sustain themselves are you kids
interested in property they are very
interested in property
yeah they're watching the youtube videos
they do watch the videos
on youtube and they've started their own
youtube channel as well
about property just because i i sit down
with them
every month or sometimes every fortnight
to discuss with them about the
progresses we've made and
teach them how to look forward for deals
online
yeah so yeah well you are a fabulous mom
and a fabulous wife and a fabulous
student and i think you deserve every
success that you've got um you know
what's it what's it been like
kind of you know the process has it has
it i mean what were the key lessons
i should say that you've learned
throughout the last two years
key lessons of lent i would say
i think if i had set back after
going to the crash course um i would not
have taken the action but um
taking action is is the key yeah so
um yeah i'm really enjoying
i'm enjoying property yeah yeah i can
say that
you're enjoying it you're also
succeeding and you're winning yeah
i'm hoping that in future maybe i can
help
youth in my church and teach them about
uh property as well absolutely i think
it's an this is and kids don't learn
about it in schools
and the whole idea and and and you know
it's
it's obvious that that's the case when
when i start teaching and put stuff on
youtube and people are so confused or
they think it's a scam or they think
that
it can't be true or it sounds too good
to be true and the reason people think
that is because
we're not taught about money and finance
and property
growing up it's kind of we're told to
just pay off our mortgage
have a job being a property entrepreneur
is
is
a foreign alien thing to most people i
think oh yeah definitely we are taught
you need to go to school make sure you
pass all your exams go to university
yeah and find a good job sometimes
you can go to university study
three-year degree go to postgraduate
and still pack your your certificate you
just be earning peanuts yeah you know
yeah yeah
so 2018 i applied to do a master's and i
just finished it a few months ago but
um i'm not really using that so when i
when i went for your crash course i just
thought i wish i had not even applied
for
for for that course because it take it
took a lot of my time
maybe i could have done a lot more in
property if i didn't have all the
assignments and starting to do
yeah but we are where we are and
everything happens for a reason yeah
and you know i mean you're such a great
example so i'm so glad that you've come
up to my house and been able to partake
in this interview
what would you say to somebody that was
thinking about
going on the crash course but they're
feeling a bit skeptical a bit unsure
what would you say if someone has been
through it i would say
just go just go and
feel the atmosphere at the crash course
whether it's online
or physical training attend
it will change your life it will change
you your life
i mean um psychologically
for even from there you you come out
feeling positive
you know that if i can do it myself so
can you
yeah yeah that's awesome well hey thank
you so much for coming on the on the
channel
and if you need anything anytime give us
a shout we're here to help
thank you for having me samuel i've
really enjoyed coming to your house i
still can't believe i've met you in
person this
is awesome thank you very much are you
so welcome
guys i think you can agree nazi is a
very inspirational lady
please do smash the like button and also
drop a nice comment below for nausea
subscribe to the channel
and every single week i have someone sit
down in my house and i interview them
and
and you can learn from not just me but
also other people that are winning
in property so do me a massive favor
subscribe to the channel you can do that
right here
if you want to see more videos like this
one you can check them out right
here and i'll look forward to seeing you
next time thanks